CONVOYED MDESS SECRETARYOHKI
T
T CONV TALKE
T N STALLE
INIAN THEY WERE ABLE TO HIT SOM
>> WHAT'S THE LATEST THAT YOU'VE
BEEN AND SEEING?ELL, TN IS SAYIN
T AT THAT T
REALLY, OB ITH
PAST STUCK
KYIV.F S
E RA ANDPE
IULAR HAV
CLESSO ADG WASLOWNS CAUSEDM TO T
THIS CONVOY DSTILL.
THINK ABT NY DAYWE ABOUTHISTRET0
AND FORMER OFFICIALS TALOUEING
ERHAVE SEEN THESIS U       UKFO
NUMBER OF THOSE HIGIVEN THE FAC
RELALYROM SUPPLY LINESO KNORUSSS
HAVE HAD A HAR
ONEY
REASSESSIN MAY BO
O SAY THAT TY ARKI M FORMIDABL
AMOUNT OF FIREWEF
ARTILLERY IN THAT .
AN ENCIR KS STILL MAD THAT JUST.
ROSTANCE NTHRITY IS STTO
KYIV BUT RUSSIAN FCEHAT THE RAPD
WE HAVE SEEN SS BYHE
UKIN THEUSAND THINNSHE
ARLL MORE RESOHE
WE
THATVERY IMPORTANTNTCAP HEARINGE
UKRAINIANS DO. THE
ALLING O NOT
OUTSID HELY
THE PED SO 92%
OF THE PCO
HEY STILL HAVE THE MAJORITY T
COMBAT POWERN
ES THE F THE
RUSSIAAVMADE MUCH SSSTILL SO MU.
AN ITHE -- THATHEY MAY BE
OF OTHER AREASRUSSIA'S F KYIV
HELICOPTERS ANJETS
PONS ANDOWERKRAINEFOR THIS EINV.
S IN UIR PUT
PLAN.THING IS GOING ACCORDINTO
WHAT'S THE YOU'VE
BEEN SEEING TODAY?EA
LOOK, AND TH
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN CLUSTER
NS HAVE SAID NOTHI
ABOUT THO UT THEATEMENTS WE'ETM
THE RUSSIA
AR RETTYEQUIVOCAL. NOT TARTI
CIVILIAN AREAS DT
ESSENTIAY N  COME TOE'VE BEEN HI
CIVILIAN AREAS AND AS THE
RUSSIAVEUSSIAN MILITARYUT IT, UO
L.
SOS TH L
WE'R
AS FAR ATHAR
CONCER OBVIOUS
THERMOBARIC TIPPED ROCKETS.ERTA
WAS MOTONTLY CONFIRM THEY ACTLLE
ED IN THAT
THE ART IOINOU
TI
SST THEY ACAUSING ANY IETHATIS S
PUTIN SAID, THEY ARELSO
TOY A W PASSED BY RITICAL SPEECD
THE SSIAN LOWER HOUSE
RLOUSE OF
PAIA TRYING LL WHICH
ESSENTIA ILLEGAL T
MASSIV UP TO 15 YEAR PRIRY AND A
AROU HUGE HEVLADIMIR P S T
THAWRTAINLY ISING G A CHILALIST,
.
THE  INSTANCE, TODAY T WAG OPER
IN THEUSANEDEFORE
CONTENLAPRIZAYIN TAKING DOIT
BECAUSE 'RHETHER
THEIR JOURNALISTS WILL HAV
GO TO IL AY KEEP REPTINGN IT.
>> IT'S A LAW ME
JOURNALISM AURATE COVERAGECAUSE
RUSSIA AHE INS ACTUALLYHAT
MARQUARDT, FRED PPRIANOW BA NEO
CRISIS.U  THE REFUGEES
NOW ENDING UP IN OTHERCON
SAE SUCH
CROSSING JUST SIDE POLAND
ALONE BORDER WITUKRAINE.RE YOUG
COLD..HAG ORY YOU . HOWSOMEET
BACKPACK
LOTS OF CHILDREN -- SOME KIDWHEG
OVER BOR
H HERE., BUT AS YOU ARSEEING ALN
AND NOW POLA HAS ABOUTALF OF
IN UKRAINE IO ANOTHECOUNTRY.
BES CAUSE OF ITS
DOORS MUCH WIDER.
NODRIVE.E, FORMPLE
THEY CAN WALK.
AND HOWEVE CTHEY WILL BE ALLOWE
BORDER.ND POLANOPLE, NO MAT T
OR WHHE
SAYLL B CROSSY AND OUT OF A INT
RE THE AND
I WAS A SNIPER IN AFGHANISTAN,
AIRPT.D TO PUST OF PEOPL
ATQUWE
THAT WE NOTICEBORDERG .
THEY FRENCH.
FROMOFHE THAT THEYERVETERANS OF
UKRAINE, FIGHT
THEYREEDOMGHAGAINST  AIN WHA
MMTHEY SD THISDU
Y ARG IND TRY ANHELPKRAINE PEOP.
AND THAT HAY HAD SOMEONE MEETING
UKRAINLL SG.RA, VING SOMISSUES E
WHERE AREY DETH  HOSS, LR ST 4
WHAT'S GOING TO THEM
SEE SO MUCH PPLCH
OW'SES
FRANKLY, MOST OF THEM
HAVE NO IDEA
ON FAMILY LAST NIGHT WHO
.ERCL.E INTO A SHELTER AND N OU
GET HERE FAST HEY CO
JUSTTENTUALTRAIN.
TRYING TO RE THECOULD GOING TO
NONGGOINW UP THE
THG HT
SO PEOPLE DON'T KNOW.ME OF THEM
A N N FOINTOR LIVES.
ING WERE HEARI
E LOPEOP